now the u.s supreme court could soon end
the nationwide legal right to abortion
in the u.s by overturning the landmark
roe versus wade decision that's
according to a leaked draft opinion
obtained by news outlet politico the
unprecedented leak sent pro-choice and
anti-abortion protesters rushing to the
supreme court the court has been
considering challenges to state abortion
laws with a decision expected in june
and we can get more from our
correspondent sumi sumiskanda who's in
washington dc
sumi can you tell us more about this
leak
anya this really has unleashed an
earthquake here in washington this news
broke relatively late into the evening
and it immediately sent shock waves not
just through the capitol but also well
beyond across the country as you said
this is unprecedented to see a draft
majority opinion from the court leaked
and i think it really underlines the
explosive nature of this case and what
this ruling
might mean and i say might because we
don't know who leaked this document we
don't know yet if it's authentic and we
haven't yet seen a comment from the
supreme court but what we have seen is
protesters taking the streets
in washington in front of the supreme
court even though it's essentially the
middle of the night uh pro-choice and
pro-life protesters facing off against
each other we've also seen democratic
lawmakers on all of the major networks
here
raising the alarm bells over what they
see as a fundamental undermining of
rights if this decision were to go ahead
republican lawmakers on the other hand
they are decrying the leak itself saying
it threatens the court's independence so
it would be a sweeping decision and
already is one that is having serious
consequences on you
sumi you've made clear that this is not
a given but if the court does overturn
roe versus wade now that would obviously
have huge ramifications for abortion
rights and for women across the u.s
wouldn't it
that's right and the impact on you would
be immediate it means that women in many
parts of the u.s would not have access
to an abortion there are a number of
republican states that have something
called trigger laws on the books and
that means that they have law stating
that if roe v wade is overturned
abortions are immediately banned in
those states and if you look at what uh
supreme court justice samuel alito who
if this draft is authentic what he wrote
in his opinion he says that this should
be returned to the states that they
should decide and we're seeing
democratic governors lawmakers as i said
uh they are saying that they will
protect the right for women to have an
abortion so anya what you could see is a
map in the u.s where you have democratic
states blue states that will allow
abortions conservative republican states
where it will be banned and women in
those states could have to travel
hundreds of miles to access an abortion
and i just want to add that we have in
many ways seen this coming and a lot of
republican states have already been
rolling back the access to abortions
oklahoma last week passing a law
banning abortions after six weeks and
the former president donald trump also
appointing three conservative justices
to the supreme court and that really
shifted the balance of this court so
we're seeing that impact now um just
briefly sumi could i ask you could this
have implications for the midterm
elections coming up this november
yeah definitely for both parties on the
one hand for the republicans they can
sell this as a win they have many
conservative socially conservative
republicans have been calling for this
campaigning for the since roe v wade was
passed in 1973 especially conservative
christians on the other hand it could
galvanize democratic and moderate voters
we know that president biden democrats
are not particularly popular right now
so this could be something that drives
them to the polls come november
sue me some of scanda in washington dc
thanks so much